Here at Yale we're committed
to improving the world today
and for future generations
through outstanding research
and scholarship, education,
preservation and practice.
Generations of generous
alumni and friends have,
through their financial support,
ensured that we can fulfill
this commitment.
Helping us to sustain current
programing, fund new ambitions,
and guarantee
that future generations
may pursue excellence
just as we do today.
Our donors' generosity
established Yale's endowment,
which with careful stewardship,
provides a long term
and stable source of revenue
for the university
and underpins the sustainability
of Yale's mission
and the fulfillment
of our strategic vision.
This video will explain
how the endowment works,
what restrictions are placed
on its use,
and its impact
on the university and beyond.
[reflective music]
(Scott)
The university endowment
is made up of almost 8000
different accounts.
These are contributions
that have been made
by individuals over the decades,
and some of them
are restricted in their use
and that the donor had
a particular interest in mind of
how they wanted
to support the university
That might be for a scholarship.
It might be for a particular
unit or department.
And so these would be restricted
endowments,
and about 75% of the total
university endowment
is under these
restricted accounts.
So we have an obligation
as a university
to utilize the funds
in a way consistent with how the
the donor
made their contribution.
And we do that,
we do that very carefully.
Which means that although
the endowment is quite large,
it is also quite restricted
as we utilize
those funds for various parts
of the university operation.
Endowment income contributes
a third of the revenue
that comprises the annual
operating budget,
making it the university's
largest revenue source.
Over the course of a decade,
the university spends
half of the value
of the endowment.
So an endowment
is really very different
than a savings account.
If you think about a family's
savings account,
families save usually
to make a big expenditure.
So they might be saving to buy
a house or a car or pay
for their children's education,
or they might be saving
for an emergency,
kind of an emergency fund.
But ultimately,
those savings are meant
to be spent at some point
and that's not the case
with an endowment.
An endowment is invested
in the earnings on
the endowment can be spent, but
the endowment itself can't be.
James Tobin developed the idea
of intergenerational equity.
James Tobin was an economics
professor at Yale
and a Nobel Prize winner
and also
my macroeconomics professor
in graduate school at Yale.
And it was the notion
that an institution like Yale
has an obligation
to today's students and scholars
but also to maintaining
that excellence over time
and making sure
that it has the resources
for future scholars
and students.
So by spending from the earnings
you support the mission
of the institution not just
today, but in the future.
[upbeat music]
The management of the endowment
is is a team effort.
Obviously,
the broader administration
and the Yale Corporation
are involved in overseeing it.
But the day to day
management of the endowment
is run
by the Yale Investments Office,
which I'm fortunate enough to
to lead.
That group of people,
which is largely made up of
Yale alumni, was drawn here
for a number of reasons.
I think the collegial culture,
the ethically
scrupulous decision
making that I think we've been
known for for a long time.
And then finally,
just the ability
to give back to the mission
of the institution
that, again,
so many of us benefited
from ourselves
as students, brought together
this group of people
who run the endowment
for the
benefit of the community.
[sound of bike passing by]
Our strategy is actually fairly
simple.
It's to take a long term
approach.
That's one of the core
advantages we have in the market
as a multi-hundred year
old institution
that expects to be around
for a while
still, relative to other players
who might be looking at
quarter to quarter results
in the financial markets.
We can take a longer term
approach and partner
with some of the best investors
in the world.
Over a 30 year
period, Yale's investment
strategy has added over
$30 billion in value
relative to a passive strategy
that would allocate
60% of its holdings
to stocks and 40% to bonds.
Each year,
Yale aims to spend
five and a quarter percent
of the endowment's value,
the amount
projected to be sustainable
given reasonable long term
growth expectations
and the endowment's
investment returns.
Because long term higher
education inflation averages
about 4% a year,
the endowment needs to grow
by approximately
nine and a quarter percent
each year,
net of gifts and transfers
in order to maintain
its real value
while also providing operating
funds to the university.
The endowment spending
policy balances two goals,
and those goals are kind
of in conflict with one another.
On the one hand, we want steady
funding for the programs
and operations that the faculty,
staff and students depend on.
And on the other hand,
eventually the spending
that we have has to reflect
the resources we have.
That is,
the value of the endowment.
The endowment spending
rule balances those two goals
by smoothing fluctuations
in the value of the endowment
and slowing the incorporation
of those changes
in the value of the endowment
into the budget.
The way this smoothing works
is that every year
the spending from the endowment
is calculated
and we have a target
spending rate
of 5.25% of the endowment's
value.
The smoothing equation
calculates
20% of each year's endowment
spending by applying the target
spending rate: 5.25%,
to the endowment's fiscal year
end market value
from two fiscal years prior.
The other 80% comes from
the previous year's spending.
The smoothing rule means that
the 40.2% return in 2021 isn't
reflected as a 40.2% increase
in spending the next year.
Instead, it's averaged
into the budget over time,
beginning with the fiscal year
2023 budget.
That year,
the endowment will provide $1.7
billion to the annual budget,
an increase of
about $170 million
or about 10%
over the previous year.
It would also work
the other way.
Say the endowment
were to experience a -25%
return one year which is what
happened in fiscal year 2009.
The effect
of that return wouldn't
be felt in the endowment
spending for two years
allowing the budgeting process
to make gradual adjustments
rather than more
severe disruptions
to the university's
core mission.
And even then it
would be averaged in over time
just as positive returns are,
so that endowment spending
would decrease
by a much smaller
percentage in the short run
than the investment
return might suggest.
[inspiring music]
The endowment supports
every aspect of the university,
everything from scholarships
that are provided to students
so they can study here
to the salaries
that support the faculty
and staff that work here,
you see that
in the form of new buildings
that have been constructed,
such as the humanities
quadrangle that recently opened.
But it's not just buildings.
It's also the academic side
of things.
What happens in our offices,
what happens in our libraries,
what happens
in our laboratories.
So the idea of being able
to build a quantum computer
is something that is supported
by the endowment.
Finding solutions
to the various aspects
of climate change
that are facing our planet,
that is supported
by the endowment.
Trying to understand
human cognition
and how the brain functions.
That's part of what is supported
by the endowment.
So as you think about
the university,
basically every aspect of it
in some form or another
is supported by these
endowment funds
that we have available to us.
If you ask the question
how much does it actually cost
to provide an undergraduate
education at Yale,
the answer is it's about twice
the cost of what we charge.
So even students
that are paying full price
for their tuition at Yale,
and many students are not,
but even those that are paying
full price
are still being subsidized
by about 50% relative to the
actual cost of their education.
Those that are receiving
substantial financial aid are,
of course, even further
subsidized.
Yale has been unique.
It's one of the really
handful of institutions
that is able to attract students
and admit students
irrespective
of their ability to pay.
And so if you are a
talented person
anywhere in the world
and you want to go to Yale
and you can't,
your parents can't afford it.
Yale will make that possible.
And the endowment
is critical to that.
When you think of
all the people's lives
it has touched
as an institution.
They've gone on
to make contributions
in their community
and the world.
It's an amazing thing.
And what's really exciting
about the endowment today
is that our plans at Yale
are so ambitious.
We're trying to do things
that will
really change the world
in really meaningful ways.
You have brilliant people
at the institution
who are motivated to tackle
some of the world's
most challenging problems
and if you want to fund people
to take on new challenges,
you have to keep increasing
your endowment.
Our donors are,
you know, absolutely critical
to the future of the university.
They want to fund efforts
that will solve the great
mysteries of life and that will
you know, really move the needle
in terms of profoundly
changing the world.
(Matt)
Our goal is to support
the university's mission
in perpetuity.
And we believe
that careful stewardship
of the endowment
is critical to that mission.
That's what we spend
every day here thinking about.
That's what my colleagues
and I wake up in the morning
coming to the office to do.
And that's why we're all
here, to give back to Yale.